honey boo boo hey thanks survive just by
finishing fourth from the bottom but
you're not gonna shake her confidence no
no best thing about doing the show so
far artim that is so sweet
I miss me are you trying to bribe me
something up too strict in the rehearsal
is that's what happening right now
no Artemis like get your base try it
seems the sassy 13 year old has met her
match and mentor Artem and junior pro
partner Tristan who's won two national
titles what has it been like teaching
her how to dance it's been a mixture of
good stressful making me angry the
chapter you're just walking I'm not
doing like this I know he feels that but
times a million more than me
last night we saw mama June in the
audience cheering on her daughter who
scored a 19 out of 30 and Alana says her
feet are really feeling all the
rehearsals I'm sore blisters yeah I was
like - on the back of my fear right now
do you think about it can you win would
you think cuz I know luckily I mean
whenever like confident
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]